shaker
sheesh that was a close one
hey come on up here water Skylanders are
stronger here so like are you good guy
now or something so like are you good
guy now or something
oh you smell another bandit ripped your
shirt listen crash I'm positive I saw
this guy way up the mountain dancing
around in some kind of giant crazy Robo
suit badly he's so offbeat it's creating
all these bad vibes across the island
well let's see you're the receive
Schmidt but I guess that means it might
not be all cortexes fault
don't suppose you know anything about
this do you cortex
whoa hey hold up ah those terrible
sounds from the mountain messed up the
smashing rockers grew big-time the auto
smashers won't act right without some
smooth rhythm the bhaktir which is your
fault
vortex you better hurry up and dig out
my funky won't a mixtape you'd see one
of the boxes below
my next take get ready to get your
groove on smashing rockers it's time to
dance this security system was designed
to repel tiny fat-headed men just like
you cortex so far it's done a great job
of keeping the village safe so safely
back that
we don't remember how to turn them off
sorry
good luck fire Skylanders are stronger
here
metronome